the Joe Rogan experience now we're
getting to the end of your hour here so
climate change is obviously an enormous
issue for our country and for the world
what what could be done and what do you
think you can do as president that can
somehow another slow down this this
process well first of all we have to
have a president who unlike Trump
beliefs and science that I do and what
the scientists are telling us as I
mentioned earlier is that we have fewer
than 12 years to transform our energy
system or else there will be irreparable
damage done not only to our country but
to the world
now climate change is not just an
American issue so we could do tomorrow
do all the right things but of China and
Russia and India and the rest of the
Brazil and Africa does not do the right
thing you know we're not gonna make the
progress we need so here is what we have
to do in my view number one we have to
tell the fossil fuel industry that their
short-term profits and they make a whole
lot of money their short-term profits
are not more important than the future
of this planet I don't think that's a
hard sell to make you cannot keep
producing a product which is destroying
the planet in the United States and
around the world so by saying that
you're saying you would have to move we
would have to move consciously away
Absalon fossil fuels no if so but soon
maybe if we do that how do you tell the
fossil fuel companies do you tell them
you can't sell fossil fuels anymore
there are a variety of ways to do that
but that is the bottom line and and by
the way in the midst of that we do what
we call is a a just transition the guy
out on the oil rig today simply wants to
feed his family and the coal miners
today want to feed their families and
we're not gonna leave them I'm a pro
worker I've probably the strongest pro
worker record of any member of the
Congress so it is not my intention to
throw these guys out on the and women
out on the street and ignore the pain
that they will go through we are
proposing billions of dollars to rebuild
those communities and make sure that
those guys and women get new jobs so
we're not just discarding people in the
fossil fuel industry but ultimately the
product
they are producing which is now carbon
emissions is destroying the planet so we
have to move away from fossil fuel in a
very bold way into energy efficiency
right now in my own state of Vermont and
all over this country there are
buildings which are incredibly wasteful
we don't have the windows we don't have
the insulation we don't have the roofing
the doors that we need to keep the
buildings warm in the winter and cool in
the summer and we can create just an
incredible number of jobs just
retrofitting our buildings second of all
we need to move very aggressively to
sustainable energies like wind and so in
California you're doing a good job with
wind
Iowa's doing good job Texas doing a good
job we got to do much more solar there
is incredible potential out there prices
solar has dropped in recent years and we
have got to not only transform the
energy system in our own country we got
to lead the world in working with Russia
and China because in this issue we are
in it together
and here's my dream and maybe this may
be a utopian dream the world right now
is spending a trillion and a half
dollars on weapons of destruction
designed to kill each other and maybe
just maybe if we had a kind of leader
and I hope to be that leader who says to
the world instead of spending a trillion
and a half dollars killing each other
maybe we use those resources to
transform the global energy system and
save the planet for our kids and our
grandchildren that's the goal that I
have well these these ideas sound great
but in the competitive environment of
global politics how would you convince
Russia or China or any of these
countries to do something that would put
them in some sort of a competitive
disadvantage well and the answer is Joe
if we do not do that in 50 a hundred
years everybody is going to be terrible
disobey you know I'm saying you know I'm
not telling you that tomorrow it's gonna
happen but you got to make the case
these people you know Putin is a
dictator I dislike them intensely you
know Qi and China very authoritarian
self on top but they're not crazy people
and presumably they have concern about
their kids and their grandchildren this
is a planet under siege you know I don't
want to become a science fiction you've
all seen the movies of the media racing
toward Earth we're gonna blow up
what do we do well we got to get
together this isn't a sense what that is
about you know when I think about in
1941 after Pearl Harbor all right we
were faced with a war in the East with
China a war in the West in Europe with
Hitler within two years the United
States had transformed its economy to
address and win the war basically in two
or three years by reindustrialize imir
we can do it we can lead the world
that's what we have to do so in your
eyes we have to look at the economy
almost as if the same kind of threat or
excuse me the environment has if it's
the same kind of threat as Nazi Germany
back together look if you asked the
defense the pomp you ask the CIA you
asked the fence people all over the
world tell us what the great national
security threat is you know what it is
it is climate change there's a lot of
people though that are skeptical that's
how would you convinced I mean this is a
big part of the problem right there's a
narrative that you hear from a lot of
people that oh you know climate change
is not approved in science and climate
change is a hoax and I mean this is
something that's repeated over and over
again and I'm sure some of it has to do
with lobbyists and some of it has to do
with merchants of doubt' that go out
there and seed the world with
disinformation to try to increase their
profits and continue the practices that
they're currently enjoying you know Joe
what I'm thinking back I don't know if
all you listeners can't remember this
cuz Mulder the most but I can remember
tobacco and cigarette ads on television
yes doc the guy dressed in a white [ __ ]
smoking away this is a great cigarette
will improve your health
they lied the tobacco industry knew
exactly what was going on and the fossil
fuel industry is lying right now and the
President of the United States is either
too stupid to understand what the
scientists are telling us or he is lying
as well Klein would should look I am not
the scientist there's not my idea I
listen to the scientist the debate is
long over climate change is real my god
look at what's happening around the
world hey the worst you know July was I
think the warmest July or warmest month
in in the modern history of the world
the Arctic ice is is melting heat waves
in Europe all right just look out the
window at what's going on
so this is not Bernie Sanders talking
this is the scientific community climate
change is real it will only get worse if
we do not act boldly to cut carbon
emissions